what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and today i will be
breaking down what could be the craziest
twists yet
in the boku no hero story not one but
two massively important characters
appear to have been
gravely injured and a secret force
within shigaraki
may have just taken over his body
this is insane you better believe that
mha has been trending
worldwide because of what just happened
so let's get
into it if you enjoyed the boku no hero
content on this channel and you want us
to
keep it going please leave a like to let
me know it really does help
and if you're new to the channel or you
just haven't subscribed don't forget to
subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
anime uproar finally as usual this video
will contain boku no hero manga
spoilers we are talking about all the
latest events in the boku no hero
stories so please proceed with caution
you have been warned at the end of the
previous chapter
deku had just landed a big hit on
shigaraki's midsection
and things were looking pretty good for
the heroes but
in my previous mha video i speculated
that this would
change the tables will turn yet again
and shigaraki will regain
the upper hand unfortunately for the
heroes that is exactly what happened
in this latest installment of the story
we start off with a quick reminder that
after he broke his arms a bunch of times
while he was still learning to master
one for all
deku was warned that if he keeps
overexerting his arms
in this way he could end up losing the
use of both of his
arms permanently if this were to happen
it would shatter deku's dream of
becoming the greatest hero
so deku took these warnings seriously
and that's when he began
focusing on his kicks but back on the
battlefield in the present time
or rather up in the air over the
battlefield shigaraki and deku
are still at it deku is using float and
black whip to keep himself
and shigaraki in the air and since he is
using his legs to propel himself and
also to avoid the recoil
deku has no choice but to use his arms
to land hit after hit
on shigaraki deku delivers a detroit
smash a wyoming smash
and a saint louis smash in rapid
succession
and the force of deku's constant attacks
is so strong that shigaraki
is unable to regenerate in time
shigaraki realizes that if he doesn't do
something quickly
deku's attacks will blow him away at
this point shigaraki is very annoyed by
the fact that the immense power of one
for all
is standing in the way of his dreams
deku proclaims that that
is exactly what the power of one for all
is for
and so deku continues to attack
shigaraki with
everything he's got delivering an
incredible texas smash
straight into shigaraki consistent with
what we saw in the previous chapter
deku is completely disregarding his own
safety
and his own well-being he is clearly
pushing himself to the limit
and beyond for the sake of protecting
everyone else from shigaraki
but this is putting a tremendous strain
on deku's own body
including his already injured arms at
first
manuel and the other heroes are shocked
by the fact that deku appears to be
dominating shigaraki in a fight but
bakugou
knows better bakuga warns that deku
cannot keep this up for long
because at this rate he is going to
destroy himself
deku might be doing an incredible job at
the moment but this showdown in the air
has now become a war of attrition
deku has to keep shigaraki in the air
and also keep attacking him with
everything he's got at the same time and
the fact is that
deku simply will not be able to sustain
this level of intensity
against a guy with super regeneration in
a matter of minutes
deku could run out of steam and at that
point he would be swiftly defeated and
his quirk would be stolen
by shigaraki if that were to happen it
would be the end of the heroes and quite
possibly the end of the entire hero
society
for his part shigeraki is definitely
concerned
about deku's attacks and on the inside
he is desperately searching through
all for one for a quirk that will be
useful against deku
in this current situation and as the big
battle between shigaraki and deku is
playing out
in the air above bakugou goes on to play
an extremely important role
in this chapter out of everyone present
on the battlefield
bakugou knows deku the best and unlike
most of the people there
bakugou knows the true nature of deku's
power
this is why bakugo recognizes that
deku's current situation
is in fact dire and he knows this to be
the case
even when everyone else might think that
deku is actually winning the fight
so instead of just waiting to see what
happens bakugo instructs todoroki to
keep
cooling endeavor off bakugo then
prepares to work with todoroki
in order to get endeavour close enough
to shigaraki for the number one pro hero
to unleash one final epic attack
together todorokinbakugo used their
quirks to keep endeavour cool
while also launching him up into the air
as they make their way towards shigaraki
bakugou reflects on his past and on his
relationship with deku
in particular he thinks back to the days
when he used to bully deku
he thinks back to the times that they
all used to look up to all might as
children
and it is clear to me that after
everything that's happened between them
bakugou has an enormous amount of
respect
for deku deku has endured many hardships
in his life
including the bullying from bakugou and
others deku has worked hard he has
sacrificed a lot
and he did everything he could to help
others
jakku is the person who always does his
best
the person who puts the needs of others
before his own
and the person who is willing to
sacrifice himself
for the well-being of others it is clear
that despite all of his tough talk
bakugou actually admires and respects
deku
and in that moment bakugou makes up his
mind
that he will help deku in this fight no
matter what it takes
bakugo will not let deku carry this
burden alone so he and todoroki managed
to get endeavour
up to shigaraki and endeavour grabs the
villain and then
in the very next moment endeavor
unleashes his prominence burn
super move as a result of this massive
attack
shigaraki's body is basically burnt to a
crisp
and for a brief moment it seems as if
the battle
might be over but then somewhere deep
within shigaraki
he hears that voice again shigaraki
hears
all for one calling to him telling him
to hand his body
over to him back when he first awoke and
unlocked the powers of all for one
there was a moment when all for one's
consciousness seemed to briefly take
over
shigaraki's body and when that happened
shigaraki called the original one for
all user his
brother even though shigaraki of course
doesn't have a brother
by all accounts this seems to have been
all for one himself
speaking through shigaraki's body at
that point
i theorized that perhaps all for one's
consciousness
or at least a part of his consciousness
had remained
inside all for one's quirk factor i also
speculated that
maybe all for one's real plan was not to
have shigaraki succeed him
but rather to take over shigaraki's body
so that he could have a new young body
instead of his own
old and injured one we know that back
when he was injured by all might
all for one anujiko had not yet
discovered the super regeneration quirk
and because of that all for one could
never use that quirk to recover his body
but now that shigaraki does possess this
quirk
if all for one really was to take over
shigaraki's body
he would have everything that he needs
to once again
become the greatest power in all of
japan
even though i had mentioned this theory
at the time shigeru seemed determined to
carve out his own path
and he pushed all for one's
consciousness to the back of his mind
however now that we actually saw all for
one's consciousness
telling shigaraki to hand his body over
to him
the theory that all for one might be
attempting to permanently take
control of shigaraki's body seems more
plausible than ever
in his moment of desperation facing off
against a full power deku
shigaraki seemingly accepts all for
one's proposal
the next thing we know those same red
and black spikes that all for one had
used in the past
to forcibly activate the quirks of
others suddenly emerge from shigaraki's
body
first the spikes pierce through
endeavour's body
and endeavour releases his grip on
shigaraki and begins to fall to the
ground
then those long tentacle-like spikes
rush towards deku all for one within
shigaraki's body
asks the original one for all user how
come he won't
die and for a moment it really looks
like deku's luck has
finally run out as the visibly injured
and exhausted deku
braces for impact bakugou uses his quirk
to propel himself
into the path of the spikes so bakugou
sacrifices himself in order to save deku
and his body is pierced in multiple
places
including his shoulder and his torso and
as we all read this on the edge of our
seats wondering what just happened to
endeavor
and to bakugou this absolutely shocking
chapter
ends man we suddenly went from deck when
the heroes controlling the fight
to both endeavour and bakugou being
seriously injured or worse
and we saw shigeraki's body apparently
being possessed by the consciousness
of all for one himself wow
we saw two important characters suffer
potentially fatal
injuries we also saw a massive change
within shigaraki
a change which might be temporary or a
change which could have
earth-shattering long-term impact if it
really turns out that all for one's
consciousness
just took over shigaraki's body for good
and on top of all of that
i'm also finding myself extremely
curious about this quirk that shigaraki
just
activated in the past we saw these
tentacles spike things
being used to force another person's
quirk to activate
and with kurogiri this was done even
when kurogiri himself was
unconscious but in this case this quirk
seems to have been used as an offensive
quirk that pierced through endeavour and
bakugou with ease
what do you guys think is the true
nature of this quirk
is its primary purpose to force the
quirks of others to activate
or is the true nature of this quirk
something completely different
also what do you guys think is going to
happen to bakugou and endeavor now
do you think that either of them could
actually be dead
personally i don't think that bakugou
will die
mha has definitely killed off characters
in the past and people dying is not
something new
in boku no hero but this series has
never killed off a character who was
nearly as important as bakugo so my
money
is on bakugou surviving also endeavour
might die eventually and i can see how
his potential death
might serve the plot the death of the
number one pro hero would signal the
beginning of a new darker era of the
story and the
end of the hero society as we know it
and of course if endeavour
ends up sacrificing his life say to save
shoto
this would complete his redemption arc
albeit in a tragic way
but still even if this were to happen i
don't see endeavour dying before
dabi shows up in jakku so i think he'll
survive this
as well nevertheless even if bakugo and
endeavor do survive which i think they
will
we shouldn't get too comfortable i have
a suspicion that we may see a major
death
soon someone like gran torino or maybe
even all might could lose their lives
in the near future i can definitely see
something like that happening
but definitely let me know what you guys
think are bakugan endeavor going to make
it
and what is deku going to do now even if
both bakugou and endeavour eventually
pull through
deku is still about to lose his mind
when he sees how his friend has been
injured before his very eyes and don't
even get me started on shigaraki and the
possibility that
all for one himself just took over his
body so much craziness and so little
time
and the ark isn't even close to being
over i can't wait to see what happens
next if you enjoyed this video and you
want to see more boku no hero content
right here on the channel
don't forget to leave a like to let me
know it really does help
and if you're new to the channel or
maybe you just haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
going to miss a ton of our videos even
if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at animeopror
i want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one possible
a very special thank you to alpha sigma
and liam thompson
disciples of lord twego himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons
including ingrata the world a quiet
respect
patahifa jonathan king rothwind de ora
emperor otaku thomas jones kin mano
admirath and chris torley finally thank
you also to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan kings eldris anatoly
kazadski
angel cruz cricket xp joe stanton very
gucci
alicia octor hinokamian water bonnie
parks
jason wilson florian joanne garcia
steelers
mcshamus jessica kayla fond deadly saint
and stern hawkins if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value for
you consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar will give you
access to our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you